as the heyoka empath i can unveil your
truth and and i can help you see
the things that your your human mind
won't allow you to see
all right thomasdale5 people can check
it out man thanks for jumping on with us
for a little bit today
yeah absolutely yeah we love you man i
love you yeah i miss you man
thomas would you do a one-on-one with me
i want to show them how positive my
energy is
i listen i'm all i'm all about working
through
difficult people
back off my broccolini get your life
together
it is don't touch me bro i'm not
touching you dude
you ever had a conversation with a
four-year-old he's not and some of them
i used to work at a daycare
you did really yeah i worked on a
daycare i loved it yeah
you'd be good that was really good yeah
they loved me that was i was getting
good reviews and stuff
yeah they loved me risky now to be being
uh on a podcast and working at a
at a daycare i feel like i don't work
there no more okay
it was that equinox i'm just saying
because one of those kids grows up
equinox daycare that's those moms
dropping
kids off trying to hit that gym get the
sweat on yeah
kids that's a really good place oh they
love when i would read them the mom
takes a little too long at the smoothie
just to get another
they got two hours two hours i called
them i'm like hey
it's been two hours your mom used to
drop
us off at the um what is that place
called
ymca boys and girls club ymca yeah but
no it was a different place like
um your uncle's house nope
it was a um the park
no it's smaller than yes it's like a
building it's a building
uh a barn a bar not a barn a bar not a
bar oh no
no liquor that water fountain they had
two restrooms
pf changs nope damn [ __ ]
dude library
library my mom would drop us off at the
library
for like seven hours and that was like
our babysitter man
it was in there seven hours yeah and i
started off i'd be like in the kids
section reading the kids books or
whatever you know mortimer gets a hat or
whatever the different book is you know
yeah
sheldon you know catches a squirrel or
whatever the different you know book of
the week was
and then they'd have different people
come read books in there
you know they'd have like damn i don't
know maya angelou or like some
handicapped guy or somebody come read a
book
and then there's always some people that
are a little too comfortable and they
bring their blanket
and they'd have their bells and they set
up candles
go [ __ ] home i think that is their
home
that was us bro my mom would send us
with lunch pails to the library dude so
we would roll in there be like
what is going on we'll be here all day
yeah we came in like to the theme music
of like hi
ho i hope it's off to work remember
there would be late finds
uh late fees oh yeah for the books huh
bucks
and dude i remember i started off in the
kids section then i started getting a
little older and people were smoking
they had a dude up there he'd draw you a
picture of some cooter or some titty or
something for a couple
bucks you know see him and then he's in
the sci-fi section
he's always that creep in the sci-fi
section a little too into it
yeah you're walking are you like star
trek yeah he just rolls up from behind a
periodical
you've seen alien with three tits no no
i could draw it for you i'll draw it for
you but i'll give you that trusty sketch
you know
this dude was trusty and sketchy so i'm
not surprised that's what he was vending
but yeah and then next thing and then
you start looking at the pornography in
there brother the um
yeah this is old school where they had
them dirty mags no no
no no no no they had this is at a time
when they had um
art books famous art look up famous art
nick oh it's like famous french art
yeah like in titanic she's all draw me
jack
yeah yeah like she's all butt naked
famous art by yeah
look at that a couple [ __ ] right out
the gate man
call them white that's van gogh right
starry night
oh yeah no we need some more ladies
there's andrew santino right there
[Laughter]
there he is red rocket himself dang
it's like santino meet me at 145 though
yeah
he's cutting weight there yeah it looked
like he just crossed the atlantic on a
desperate ship from his homeland
he definitely looks like he's got a bit
of the uh
what is that called when you don't have
enough vitamin c in your spine chin
black plague black plague is that what
that is yeah uh
yeah let's just call it the plague let's
go with the bro science yeah
yeah but yeah you're right though those
paintings back in the day there's a lot
of
white girls with tits yeah right maybe
fit girls near a stream
sixteen hundreds
hey girls narrow stream they were always
a little thick too huh
they always had hips on them and then
they always hide their bush a little bit
with like a twig
a fig or a little bird oh there we go
now yeah
baby now we're talking big [ __ ] yeah
okay cats in the wild that's brandon
meet me at 370. god damn look at that
poor cat too
both are cholesterol's our highest one
guy
look at that and look cats right there
dangling her feet right there
too there you go
look at the gut look at the gut on that
little
thought right there look at that guy
pretending he's a gynecologist
get out of dodge buck
damn man look at donut lisa right there
meet me at four pounds three inches tall
dude that was when art was art you feel
me yeah man
that's a beautiful piece but dude i
remember i'd go into the back of the
library i'd get one of the books with
the rubenesque ladies in it man and i
would literally
just sit there and just bone around oh
just drool
straight into the book yeah dude i drew
a half a quart right in that ass
drool and boners dog just oh it was
insane i remember
oh yeah man i remember did your mom pick
you up good day
like sure was just full of shame you
know yeah
hiding books i'd have to then yeah i'd
be in there masturbating whatever and
then hiding books and [ __ ] all in the
library dude all of this going on
people are trying to learn people are
trying to do reports while you're
jacking off
you look like you guys would fold the
pages and come back the next day in the
library hey libraries are universal man
that's your universe yeah
do whatever you want in there are
libraries still popping though they
still open those [ __ ] up
it's the airport for words man the
library yeah if you're homeless or don't
have internet
yeah those are both i worked at a
library for two years in high school
how was that it was pretty awesome i
just did the periodicals did you know
where everything was
when people were like where can i find
the tattoo
totally see you in the library sorry
interrupt you go on did you check
non-fiction
um i was pretty good at it and i bought
a portable tv
from best buy it was like 150 and it was
like three inches so i could watch
football in the back on sundays oh yeah
and lose your money
uh nope wasn't gambling then yet didn't
really didn't have a bookie i was 17. i
don't know i needed a guy
uh but there were a lot of people like
theo i was uh
yeah yeah and they would use the
internet and they would jack off like
there was one guy he was a big indian
scoundrels man i'm pissed i basically
don't have a picture but jay greengrass
i busted this guy
[Laughter]
i must see this guy how'd you catch him
how'd you catch him in the act he
this is really horrible i was jacking
off to where's waldo brendan
there was a child next to him and he
tapped her on the shoulder wait hold on
go on
there was a this is another dark world
of wisconsin's story
but he was looking at stuff on the
computer and and playing with himself
and there was a child next to him and he
tapped her on the shoulder and asked her
to look at it
oh no and what'd you do uh she like ran
and screamed and then
like i told the libraries they called
the cops and they took them away
you have a whistle or something do they
give you what you would you get
i just started waving my arms but you
can't be loud so you're like this
oh yeah you can't be loud just waving
your arm
[Laughter]
uh playing some rays they're like
there's a fire you're on fire you're on
fire
you're on fire uh your crotch is on fire
uh one word one
need relief look at his offense cause
child to view or listen to sexual
activity oh
nick got him tight moved dog good job
nick
saving one kid at a time so nick was
basically a narc before he
was did you walk up and go want to have
a seat
i'm already [ __ ] sitting jacking off
what are you talking about i take
offense to being compared to this
guy i know right now yeah that's not
nice
you were just hanging out in the airport
you guys unfortunately there's a lot of
guys like theo in those libraries
feels not like this man dude i was
reading books i had to go
write research the author he's trying to
learn bro
find the art and then touch myself yeah
this guy wasn't learning
this guy doing shorthand over here just
googling it on the web
jay greengrass yeah obviously native
american
he was he was j.a greengrass obviously
gonna assassinate a politician any day
now
didn't you say you would put your wiener
in between the pages and just squeeze
the books together yeah i would
but he wasn't tapping nobody on the
shoulder you know he's doing it by
himself in the corner
i would be pissed if i wanted that book
it was like here you
oh my god dude why you got your why you
got your dick in a [ __ ] headlock with
the book
why are you doing that to those books
doug nobody's believing this
hypothetical situation where you want a
book okay
that's what i'm finding that's the only
part of having
don't make this about me let's go back
to you smashing your dick
books at the library yeah [ __ ] my
education dude
you're ruining the books good books
they're good books brendan
not anymore yeah well they were like why
is this one all dented
up and this one has honey all over it
bro well the thing is this is before the
internet so you had to just
you know that's as close that's how you
did it you found a good book with
something pervy in it and you
pressure pressed your body into it i
never heard that okay
i usually back you up on stuff
but i still stand by i don't like how
nick compared you to that real
yeah you feel me yeah the real
pedophiles of kenosha
is putting me into dude can we pull up
these portland ride this [ __ ] that's
going on in the park it's literally
the portland funniest stuff i've ever if
you see can you pull up a video from it
it's not even it's almost turned into
like uh dungeons and dragons i feel like
if you look at these people in the park
it's like it's basically larp live
action role playing
oh no there's one word you know what
larp is cat
yeah i'm surprised you knew what is that
exactly live-action role-playing
oh you look at me you would get a lot of
crotch and
if you went after some of these larp
chicks i think what is that
you wouldn't be well i think chappelle
would be welcoming in i don't know if
you'd be welcome in all oh i think i
would if i came in full costume like uh
uh the hound from the throne that's a
real thing
you have to burn half your face though
which i'm willing to do to join the
group
oh damn wait is it like is it like a
again to join your group i'll slam my
dick in a buck
hey bro i want in that's cosmosis bro
you know i'm searching for that
nocturnal bust
yo man you trying to get a ring for a
girl maybe eventually dude you have to
do it
anybody all stressed out about it well i
need to do something man
i'll tell you this i'm lonely and i'm
getting older then you got to get
yourself a ring
and that's the truth brandon just start
taking a knee giving them rings dude see
what happens when you've got a diamond
ring on your hand
maybe some high-end jewelry around your
neck i'm talking about that bluenile.com
the original online jeweler well you
wear a lot of jewelry and have a lot of
more
you know that's more year i feel like um
you know you're
you can be yours too man you'll have to
break the bank to do it either yeah man
at bluenow.com you can celebrate all of
life's special moments dude
all of them engagement rings how about a
piece for your niece
for for who my friend no for your mice
oh for my mice yeah yeah they're all
mises oh the rat king's gotta share baby
i'll tell you this now what if i want to
get something from my buddy's little
quinceanera you know get him a little
spanish piece or what if i want to get
somebody a little uh
you know a little funeral uh item a
little ring set for a death dude
if if they're unique whatever it is bro
birthday a buddy a birthday
james remembering high-end jewelry don't
settle anymore bluenow.com choose from
more than
a hundred thousand what about yours what
if little lance does well on a
test on a spelling bee get lanced that
diamond header get em with a little
wristlet yeah why not
we'll chain around his necks brag to his
buddies whatever you want man good luck
lance
yeah lance good luck man if you if you
need help picking something dope too
blue now has diamond jewelry experts
available via phone
to chat whatever to help you through you
can start with a gemstone and work with
a blue nile jeweler to craft a unique
and one-of-a-kind piece so it's not just
all pre-made pieces and pre-designed you
can design your own things
blue nile is really the place to go with
over 165
000 ratings and counting and 90
our four stars are higher hit them with
the deal b
man they got great customer service 24
7. so if you're
you want you ready to celebrate your
love a life special moment with jewelry
from bluenow.com
well king of stinglisters you get 50 off
your first purchase of over 750 bucks
this podcast is exclusive
to diamonds as well use code kats
that's code k-a-t-s plus every order is
insured
ships free and arrives in street little
packets so nobody knows what's inside
just steal your stuff you can surprise
your husband surprise your wife surprise
your little somebody
somebody special man or woman or
whomever crossover everybody
shop stress free and find your forever
piece go to bluenile.com
today this podcast exclusive includes
loose diamonds use code cats that's code
k-a-t-s
look man i'm staying hydrated you look
hydrated man
and i'm staying hydrated i get on that
bike and i i don't go for water anymore
i go for that liquid
iv in the water site drinking three
bottles of water oh you're going down
south you're going to drip mississippi i
noticed man you're
i feel hydrated man i feel hydrated well
look man here's the thing if you're
doing running
if you're doing activity jumping leaping
and it's hot too
oh look man i know it's hard dude i've
seen it yeah replenish man you gotta
replenish it tastes great increases my
energy they got it all man how about the
flavor i know brenda but if you're
chasing a frisbee if you're doing
something if you do what you're chasing
a dog you
you know what i'm saying your aunt's dog
got loose and you gotta get out there
and get it before it gets hit by a
vehicle
it gets to that body fast too man
absorbs fast that bloodstream
instantly feel better if you're doing
track and field if just
or just track or just field if you're
just looking at a field
if you're doing something man if you're
eating boomers or whatever out there
whatever you got to do i'm saying this
stay
hydrated with liquid ivs cellular
transport technology it delivers an
optimal ratio of nutrients for your more
efficient uptake and i notice brendan
when i drink it if you drink a regular
glass of water
you feel all right okay you drink a
glass of water with liquid iv
in it you can feel it go into your
system and look for places to help you
liquid iv is available nationwide at
costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com use the
code kats at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use the promo code kats
at liquid iv.com yup start fueling your
adventures today at liquid iv.com
promo code k-a-t-s thank you
for supporting this podcast yeah i think
larp's just our thing yeah i got to see
this larping thing you never seen and
this grown-ass adults doing larping oh
no it's a grown ass grown as a dog
and like there's a king and everyone has
to like bow down to him and [ __ ] like
it's real
[ __ ] bro you've done it before brendan
no i don't know why i know so much about
it i don't know maybe do latest can you
do latest
but there's a whole hierarchy there's
like gang that's it
this one yeah really i think that
yeah i think i got an invite to be like
a dragon you did
they invited you to larping yeah but
just to be the big thick dragon everyone
shoots at you i don't know who invited
you though i don't know something like
group
chat yeah yeah yeah they dm like go down
a little more you get a thick ass dragon
you in i was like
how do you get into the wow yeah they do
it like at the park
what are you fighting for today mike
freedom the constitution is entirety
freedom from the boot that continues to
oppress us we're tired of spitz shot in
it
we stand for freedom of all people
regardless of race religion or creed
church four looks sick
we're sick of being impressed now this
group looks like they have something
going on here they're
semi-organized i'm talking about you get
these groups
it was like it was like horrible
fighting like the fight was like
really really bad really yeah it was
just like
you know like people swinging like that
it looks
i know exactly what you're talking about
yeah it was so
freaking oh this is it i think and if
it's yeah this is it a lot of colors
yeah there was a lot of like it almost
seemed like a gay pride kind of a little
bit but with a little bit more
you know what i started to think it was
it's just the new mosh pitting that's
what this has become
i bet if you put on some darius rucker
everybody on both sides
and chill out she's a blast yeah nick
got all
lemonade yeah cold lemonade darius rocco
yeah they'll all realize they'll be like
this looks like the inside of takashi
6'9's head yeah it's just
colors chaos you don't know which side
he's on
but it's just creamy if people dress up
like a ninja turtle
it's like who would be like nobody's
fighting for
anything they have no idea well they're
just bored man so so okay so this looks
like larping so what is large
yeah that's not loud that'd be this is
ultimate larping
yeah that's ultimate larping yeah that's
like larping uh ninja warriors that's
bellator larping yeah
is larping a little bit smaller
larping's more like
um from the outside largest role-playing
festival in the world see they want to
know
yeah and they want me to be the dragon
they want to be a thick dragon float
around and get shot
this is not real i don't know man for a
certain if the price is right or even if
it's wrong get out of there
a lot of cardio a lot of cardio in that
suit running around
yes that's why they wanted me
you could train dude you could always
get into some uh
some uh look at this it's like deontay
wilder's outfit
yeah yeah there's a lot of yeah this
could be the deontay wilder fan club
see they like fake it like yeah bro you
can do oh they fake hit each other
yeah well they're like swords are like
styrofoam get some
dude you should go into civil war
re-enactments brendan
all that suit he wore and then he lost
was like that suit made me real
tired yeah
they're like didn't you try it on before
he's like yeah
oh my god who walks out like that he
does would you do that stuff like that
brittany yeah what did you do do you
have a secret
you wouldn't wear like a whistle or
something i created my own shirt i
created abbott kenny fight club shirt
you did yeah i wore that and there and i
yeah i turned down the money
what was your song you walked out to
yeah eminem square dance
i don't know if i know that one
look at look at who it is
what's up boys what's up the kobe
clairvoyant himself
one of the funniest guys i don't know
hey thomas dale what's up man
i'm good dude how are you guys good
we're doing good do you guys do you know
brandon do you know everybody in here or
no yeah of course i know brendan he's
i we perform we used to perform all
together at left factory yeah
yeah that's right i think i actually was
at one of the shows where you guys yeah
it's not fun going after thomas i just
hated following him oh he's great god
great
great bury he's really just a hit man
yeah that's why we brought you here it's
[ __ ] up man i have ptsd from it so
glad you can make it
you guys are just the same so i
appreciate that thank you thomas i'm
here too
chappelle is here and cat is here as
well you can't see
oh damn oh my little black bear that's
that's what he calls dude this little
black bear
all right hey that's between y'all
if you're in the nba you'll probably get
fined for that but that's all good
don't ask don't tell on this podcast
baby
um so thomas yeah we'd love to do you
know we we know you
like uh one way that you've like a lot
of people have found new ways to
i guess thrive during during uh core of
it and get things done and one of the
things you've done is you've really
tapped into some of your
uh other abilities will you tell us a
little bit about that real quick
yeah i mean i started um like kind of i
i wanted to disconnect a little bit from
comedy like a year ago i started kind of
transitioning out
because it just wasn't servicing my well
i hope my you know theo i mean you know
me
a little bit well like you know like i'm
just i'm just very like sensitive and
connected and just i don't know the
business just wasn't
thriving in my spirit i just wasn't
feeling happy anymore so
i slowly like i left my agent i left my
agency so i wasn't making any more money
a lot of money
i was just doing local spots and i
started ubering to get out of the
business i was like i just want to be a
regular
[ __ ] you know and i loved it so
i was in the uber and i was getting
people in the car
and then this click the clairvoyant
stuff started popping off even more i
started getting images
and messages and i started to tell them
about it i'd have people in my uber
crying
they didn't want to leave the car like
they just i i'm a heyoka
empath as well so i could unveil your
truth
i just have that ability it's like an
oracle type of thing so some people
are very either very comfortable around
me or they're very uncomfortable around
me dude if i'm gay at the end of mine i
just don't want to know that
that's the only thing yeah if i have a
heart attack for being a little out of
shape in three years don't give me a
heads up man
i'm not joking dude are some people
nervous to know their own like what
what you think i feel like some people
might be dude
yes of course there there's people that
just and to be honest with you what's
funny is
i actually prefer reading women because
guys especially straight men are a
little more closed up and a little more
tight and uncomfortable with their own
energy so
there's a lot of times where they're
just they don't let me in
you know and it's hard so there's a lot
of guys in here
there's a lot of guys in here i don't
know if they're all straight but there's
a lot of
guys in here
well so it's a little harder yeah so i
just started this at the
quarantine because people i you know
they wanted stuff and i was like you
know what i never thought of
doing it virtually i had clients coming
to my apartment and stuff
but once i did it virtually like it i
actually was able to connect better
because i wasn't feeling all this extra
energy
i i definitely can relate to being like
a sensitive person i definitely can
relate to like
yeah you've always seemed very much like
um
connected to like the feelings of what's
going on whether it's
with a person or the moment or yourself
um
and affected by those as well because
those are obviously a lot heavier in you
in your world so um
but also i would say you know from from
just my time being around you the short
times around you like you're
very loving person like it's not yeah
you're very
caring like loving a happy person
absolutely yeah
and i tend to like look into your soul
and people don't really
like that sometimes well yeah you know i
know i have a feeling we're not going to
like it but we want to have we want to
see if
is it something thomas you can do with
us for a few minutes like
on each of us or is it something that
that we can't do like that
um i mean i'm gonna i'll do it i did you
know
when i do two people at once the
energies and then especially if there's
other energies in the room
because what i'm doing is like here's
the thing let me just give you a little
science part of it
energy is just that's what a soul is
it's just energy okay
energy is like it's in it enters the
flesh the body
and it does and then it experiences
something when the body dies or just
ends the energy leaves the body they've
already calculated it like science has
already figured that out
and it goes back into the universe i'm
just connected like my therapist because
i'm bipolar i know that sounds crazy but
they said that people with that kind of
mental quote unquote mental illness
i'm just not i don't have a filter in my
brain that helps me protects me
from all this energy like the things i
feel and see
are humans really not supposed to do
that we're supposed to be able to just
accept that we're just these fleshy
bodies walking around and
nothing else is happening and i'm seeing
i can see the truth
i unveil your truth it's insane it's
damn it's a super crazy
it's it's a super power really yes yeah
i mean it's uh
it probably sounds like it's like it's a
blessing and a curse
yes it used to be a curse and now it's a
blessing and the native americans used
to call the heyoka empath
the sacred clown and sacred clown i
wound up being a [ __ ] comic
and i used to see visions in the 90s of
like the white house burning
and the fires on the land i used to tell
all my friends i
have a um a video that i did my
instagram and i tagged
all my friends from the 90s till present
day that i used to talk about this stuff
with
so that people knew i wasn't just like
oh i need something to do i'm not doing
comedy
i've been talking about this since i'm
13 about the new worlds and all kinds of
stuff
and i started comedy 14 years ago
because i figured that would be my
platform
that i would be known when the [ __ ] hit
the fan and like everything started
crumbling
they would come to the to the star
children's to the to the other guides
there you know to the people who had
different type of earth other earthly
powers you know
and here we are yeah yeah and here we
are asking you yep
exactly and now exactly and i used to
tell my friends i see walking through
the desert and
there's small communities of pockets of
communities after all the destruction
and
and the rebuilds i used to call it and i
used to say it's when i'm in my 50s and
60s when i'm an older man
i didn't realize it was gonna i mean in
the next 10 years
that's when the destruction starts and
then when we're rebuilding i'll come out
you know like not just me there'll be
other
people there's no such thing as one
leader that's an old-school thought
power even that word power is an
old-school thought it's not what we're
headed towards so
now i i'm like holy [ __ ] i never thought
i could be a medium where i speak to
spirits i
when i started practicing my
clairvoyance that's when the spirit
started coming to me jesus
so i would say to the woman yeah i'd be
like i saw a murder
this girl's throat got slurped i was
like did you just watch a horror movie i
just saw someone's throat cut slice
was it in it wasn't because i saw
something like that about sacramento
oh i don't know
yeah no i don't know that i don't know
it's just a rough stuff
i didn't know if you were already you
know if you knew what i knew but
um well you're a pisces so you probably
are able to do these things too
so are you a pisces my moon is in pisces
we're both pisces yeah two pisces oh i
thought he just guessed that right now
that you were pisces i was like two fish
bro
that's crazy fish bros well we would
love i think yeah even if
maybe do you want to do i mean would it
be easier if you just focus on one
person thomas
um the way i did giannis pappas and
krista stefano and i may i'll just we'll
just do it together and i'll see what
comes up but just
from the viewers you know because this
is something where people love to jump
down your throat and be skeptical
you know there's a lot going on in that
room right now so i'm gonna pick up on
what i pick up on
be open and when i'm telling you
something you know
think about what i'm saying if it
connects and you understand the
information
give it to me don't be like you know
it's like when you're doing comedy hell
yeah i'm nervous
no but you know when you're doing comedy
and there's like an audience that just
you know you're being funny but the
[ __ ] just won't laugh
yeah like don't be like that that's all
i'm saying you know so okay
with the truth don't be an [ __ ] hey
you're just doing brennan and theo right
we'll see
sometimes it might like pick up on that
so if you hear something that connects
with you and it's not connecting with
them
let us know i'm real nervous over there
if you feel
a dark energy let us know it's probably
nick
i think nick is a skeptic but that i
felt through instagram but whatever
um
not not looking at his instagram like
when we talked to dm me yeah and i just
felt something about nick's and the
energy about this
very skeptical yes it's all good though
nick i love you bud
i believe you dude even though
i didn't buy that yeah you said dude
yeah one time i went up on stage and it
was an entertainment hypnotist named
chris oh god
carter i'm not that yeah that's not this
bro no he couldn't crack me that's all
i'm saying
the old thomas will crack you baby okay
trust that that boy is still in here
yeah dude
you got a professional up there that
demon's still in there brother
i've seen it man yup cracking open
fellas since 91
snap crackle pops
but don't sleep on me okay
don't sleep around you okay
okay let's take a moment and let's get
ready for this i'm gonna have a little
bit yeah
it's my old school way i don't identify
as a comic anymore i identify as
heckler clairvoyant medium heyoka empath
amen
um thank you guys all right so what
we're going to do is we're going to do
two deep breaths together
we're going to go in through the nose
and out through the mouth and we're
going to do it together
because it gets me on the same when we
breathe we're kind of on the same
wavelength okay okay all right so
all right so the first breath now
okay second breath now
okay great okay so now i'm gonna be
focusing in
over here this is the higher heart i
it's like a portal for me
so i'll be like looking into that and
meditating into that space
and just telling you the things that i'm
seeing and feeling
okay brandon i'm um connecting over
towards you
stop me in my face don't worry but i'll
never hurt you yeah
i'm sorry i'm lightheaded took all the
oxygen
so sometimes i just see objects of
things something you could have thought
about or talked about or like seen or
something
and right away so it's just very like
mind reading type stuff
does an alligator did something with an
alligator happen i just was like when we
were breathing i kept
seeing an alligator and it was coming
towards over with you so it could have
been anything you could have watched a
show about anything with alligators or
talked about it or anything maybe even
with florida
or swampy type stuff do you remember
anything i'm trying to
think i mean i read uh i read up my
son's book had like alligators and
sharks in it so it could be that yeah
it's literally just as simple as that
right now it's just mind reading so
when did you read that book do you
remember uh two nights ago wow
yeah exactly so that's just in your
brain it's just the alligator so that's
it's just like you know burns in your
brain so i'm just mind reading at this
point so let me just connect keep going
thank god i don't get attacked by an
alligator no no no no it's just in the
beginning it's just like
like i'm just healing the layers exactly
yeah
sometimes with straight guys it's like
i'll be like oh what i'll see a porno
they watched earlier
like and i'll have to mention it too
sorry about that no you didn't
no nothing poor girl am i right see a me
too
claim yeah in fact right
hold on all right so also it could be
someone
trying to come through to show me
something um there's like a pearl i
know this i know you're going to make a
joke about this but there's like a pearl
necklace that i'm seeing
um on my end
i think it's on your end yeah my girl's
my girl's grandma just died on sunday
she wore a pearl necklace did she really
yes
yeah because it's coming through it's
big time so i think that that
grandmother is trying to come through
and
give me some kind of energy uh or a
message okay hold on
so that's definitely the grandmother and
it's your girlfriend's grandmother hold
on
well see i'm not gonna con i will
continue that much because you might not
know this information about the
girlfriend's grandmother
but it could be my grandma too she wore
a pearl necklace and she was
she was english she passed away okay but
that was years ago
years ago it would probably be more your
grandmother then if
okay you know what i'm saying like
because the pearl necklace i mean it
thinks that they're both that they both
wear them but
it's very specifically the pro necklace
and if she's cussing it's definitely my
grandma
she's english hold on hold on too much
information now hold on
all the time i'm having another cheese
theo i have to be honest with you though
when i was before we would come in the
past couple of days i kept seeing
this like large woman and it feels like
she was trying to connect with you
i i did her did her brother own subway
i don't know any i don't know any of
that hold on i just felt like there was
like a large woman it felt like an
aunt or a grandmother it felt like
someone in a family like a woman in your
family that passed away
that was like had a big i don't know if
there's a big person now they're just
physically large
do you know any any anyone like that in
your family big girls
my friend's fat aunt passed away but she
um
and she had a couple dogs but i didn't
really know her but
but when did she pass away probably
about maybe five years ago six years ago
okay
okay yeah there's large women
some backgrounds trying to get through
hold on i'm trying to think of who it
could be i think one of my sisters has
been putting on weight and having to
hurt from her in a while
no that wouldn't be it would be a passed
away person hold on let me just get it
get back into brendan's oh
yeah it could be this lady we were just
looking at it we were literally just
looking at this woman
with the cat and we made it did she pass
away
oh yeah yeah so there was this woman
that was coming through this big
this big but it was coming through like
a couple a day or two
sorry i wonder what she's with the cat
yeah yeah
okay hold on don't not too much
information hold on okay
i'm sorry yeah let me just stay focused
here and let me get back to brendan's uh
energy because that was where i was
being drawn to
okay so that's the pearl necklace that's
the grandmother one of the grandmothers
because now i'm getting drawn to your
girlfriend is it your you said it's your
girlfriend
my wife beyonce my wife because i was
gonna say fiance
she's hot how long ago did you guys get
married she's a cool lady
uh year and change ago so it's newer
it's
fresh yeah because i felt it being very
new like fiance type
um okay so this girl let me feel her
because now i'm seeing the girlfriend oh
that's the cat
i could give you a visual of what i see
i've never seen your girlfriend
um uh like thin girl is her hair curly
ever like does she ever curl it
sorry she has wavy hair and then uh
she's curvy girl
does she have any dog there's a dog
there's a brown there's an energy a dog
energy she ask her if she's thinking of
getting one if she doesn't have one
well her her brother has a dog he's been
bringing him over my kids love it so
we've been thinking of getting a dog
yeah exactly so definitely get that dog
because i was feeling that energy around
your especially
your wife she's feeling that brandon
your youngest one hold on there's two
i'm seeing two how many children
do you have two a four-year-old and a
nine-month-old wow yes the
nine-month-old is what i was seeing the
youngest one
um there's something about the maternal
her maternal feelings hold on
you're [ __ ] i don't think so it's
almost like this dog
will help her with it because it'll keep
the other one busy
the older the four-year-old you know
like the four-year-old because she
the four-year-old tends to be very want
to be hands-on with this baby a lot oh
yeah
yes like the four-year-old keeps wanting
to like do things yeah like really like
he's a great big brother yeah he's a lot
yes so the
the puppy will like distract that boy
well that makes sense
yeah keep them busy occupied yeah
because he's just kind of on top of her
with it
um but it's sweet it's nice it's not a
bad thing let me go over to theo because
i feel him getting distracted
you get any more big [ __ ] for theo
hold on let me just connect to you
yeah see brendan just so you know is
more open for so i could feel his
openness
okay yeah i'm a good person well theo i
know theo's is a little bit
me and theo would have to do deep work
because leo has a lot of very like
darkness a lot of
uh no not darkness at all he's actually
a beautiful spirit and that's why he has
so many walls
up because his spirit is actually really
nice
it's sensitive and he's been hurt in his
life so and that i know from my mind i
don't know like
you know i'm not saying that
clairvoyantly like i just because i do
know you do we know any comics who
aren't sensitive you know what i'm
saying like i feel like most right
oh it's a really like i'm saying you and
i are both super sensitive yeah
absolutely we're all very in tune you
know um
theo's just not comfortable with his
sensitivity yeah that's the thing okay
there's a difference
so just be open i'm not gonna i won't i
won't like share any things that you
don't want to share just let's see
just be cool yeah you're good you're
good baby you got that scarf
done you have a scarf on i know we both
do
we're the same hold on
okay so there is a there's a blonde girl
that's coming through
i knew it um are you seeing anyone yet
is there a new is there a new person
coming or an
ex or someone that you just finished up
with no i've been seeing a blonde girl
on and off for a while yeah okay so
that's that's
coming up yes blonde fun
yeah that's what i'm seeing so that girl
um hold on
she gets a little frustrated with you
put like not um
letting her in more like she or keep the
back and forth a little bit there's a
little frustration coming from her
oh yeah there is welcome to the club a
story in my life man
hold on let me i have to stay in this
because i'm getting a good read on her
i'm getting a good read too sounds like
she's sick of your [ __ ]
yeah hold on maybe every girl i've ever
met
there's actually something specific that
she's going through right now that's
making her sad
oh wow do you know what's going on no i
don't think so i don't know
i don't know and also it keeps coming up
i can't get this vision out of my head
did you see something with like it looks
like i don't know
animals it looks like a llama like
something with like a long neck
and furry it looks like one of those
it's not like just like a regular common
animal
it could be that [ __ ] do damn long
neck or it could be
is it in mexico because we're thinking
about starting a zoo in mexico
yeah we almost got into a zoo and one of
the first animals they said on
the email was uh emus or does emus have
a long neck
yeah i think so yeah it feels like
something with a long neck
it feels like a thing that i wouldn't
know the name of but i would have
compare it to a llama
so okay looks like that alpaca alpaca
yes i do have some alpaca fur at the
house
so that's why that image is coming up i
guess it's not much it's like three
cubic feet
the cartel scared us away from opening
that zoo by the way yeah the zoo went
down and there's my boy david too
straight up long neck right there out of
freaking flint michigan
i don't even know what you're talking
about oh you can't see the images huh no
i can't
i only see my images oh gotcha wow
that's crazy you have your own freaking
google image search in your head
well it's like mind reading i've
actually had to play dumb in my life a
lot
so if you've noticed like i try i play a
little aloof in social scenes or even on
stage
because i don't like to know all the
things i'm seeing
i bet you see some dark [ __ ] man you
know life comes at you fast brendan
sometimes it's not always peaks
sometimes there's some valleys you need
some help getting out of that valve oh
yeah
talk to a professional quit talking to
your friends they don't know what the
hell they're talking about well look at
frankie valley
look what happened to him man there's a
lot of uh there's a lot of times you're
gonna need help you're gonna need that
outreach
license professional you know and that's
where better help
will help you they will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating
in less than 48 hours and sometimes even
sooner than that
yeah it's worldwide man it's worldwide
you can send your
counselor a message any time you want
yeah you're having a tough moment you're
not sure
yourself it's you can ask for help it's
more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and finance financial
aid is also available
better health wants you to start living
a happier life today
yep when i was young you know people
would need help and they couldn't get it
you'd see somebody would
uh you'd see somebody or you'd see
everybody would have little signs in the
window say help want it
you know and it would just break your
heart but now now people can get help in
fact so many people have been using
better help
that they are recruiting they are
recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
wow special offer for king and the sting
listeners get 10
off your first month of therapy and help
and assistance
at betterhelp.com k-a-t-s
don't be ashamed you know i just reached
out to my therapist yesterday and i hit
her up and i said hey i need to start
seeing you again
and it's going to be over face time you
know she can't do it in person because
she's afraid of the disease
but she's still doing it and you can do
it too special offer for kingdom sting
listeners 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com k-a-t-s
i think your mom is showing up to me too
now mom is coming in on my left when
they come up on my left that means on
earth is your mom alive or passed away
she's alive okay so she comes on earth
sometimes when they come on the left it
means they pass away but quick
but when it's 95 sometimes on earth on
the left so she's alive
i'm seeing her did she used to smoke
cigarettes or is she still smoking
cigarettes
she i don't i don't think she smokes
them anymore but i wouldn't be shocked
if she did smoke him at some point
but okay yeah because i'm seeing
something about smoking cigarettes i
could see her puffing something i used
to see her maybe with a door al every
now and then when i was growing up
she's also intensely wearing thinking
about something too
oh that's her hold on i know people be
like oh everybody's always thinking
about something but she's always
thinking about something man
intensely though like obviously there's
something i see her like got
gazing out and like looking there's
something she's thinking about
um there's a sister that she's thinking
is do you have a sister
you have a sister okay so um what is she
there's something about a baby and a
sister um
yeah is she is she did she just have a
baby or she like what
one of my sisters might have a bad i
haven't talked to one of them in about a
year she might have a baby i don't know
i wouldn't
know you guys aren't close we're not
close so she wouldn't tell me if she had
a baby
no stop it you'd have to know well she's
either pregnant or how old is she
if you don't well can we say that no we
don't want to yeah i think she's
probably about 30.
okay so she's yeah i think she's gonna
be having a baby soon she's gonna either
be pregnant now or getting pregnant is
she dating somebody is she with somebody
i think she's been kind of shacking up
with some fella you know
okay well she might not want to be
pregnant so you might want to like give
her that um
give her the update okay wow if she's
unlike that fella i'll maybe shoot her a
text
yeah there's something about a baby
going happening and you're my and your
mom is like thinking worried
there's something about your mom and
your sister your mom worries about your
sister
about some stuff going about oh yeah
definitely she's always worried about
her
yeah your mom and your sister your mom
definitely stresses out about your
sister um
because they used to do some i think one
of them might be you know
who knows they might be doing what pills
i think yeah there's something happening
that's stressing your mom out about your
sister
and then there's this baby that keeps
pop this kid keeps popping up
um but since you don't know specifically
you could ask her and find out and then
you know be like oh my god i can't
believe that you know that's what
usually happens people don't know in the
moment even though
oh i asked her she's usually a [ __ ]
about a lot of the [ __ ] but i will ask
her
but i know maybe this will bring you
guys together that's true that's a good
point man okay hold on
look at that yep brendan huh maybe she
hasn't told anyone she's pregnant you
call her up and you're like are you
pregnant
how you know i love you yeah it's true
she's either pregnant now or getting
pregnant or there's a
something happened with a baby with her
so she just had an abortion or she's
getting pregnant or she's on
accidentally really
yeah find out it no it could be anything
she you know but it could be
something about it i'm just saying
something about a baby with her gotcha
okay
your mom is stressed out about her okay
so brendan there's something about a
father coming through here hold on
is it my dad judging me hold on so
your dad's dad your grandfather he's not
alive right no sir
yeah so he's coming through and he's
telling me something about with your dad
hold on
so the the grandfather showing me some
it's like a gun which usually
um means like um which usually means
like
army or military yeah yep he was a uh
he was in the army in world war ii
really yes
killed nazis yeah so that's exactly what
he's showing me so that's the
grandfather
and he's showing me something about your
dad so your dad um he's coming through
in the middle which usually means like
um
because your dad's alive right yes sir
yeah so when they come in the middle
that means that they're either
going through something whether it's uh
mental illness or dementia or drugs and
alcohol or some kind of stress
or so it keeps them from being here and
like they're like
here and there yeah i haven't heard from
like usually i talk to him every week i
haven't heard from him in a little while
yeah i would just find out there's
probably this there's just something
that he's going through i know he's
scared of corona like as soon as cnn
launched some [ __ ] campaigns they uh
on corona he hasn't left the house
he won't leave the house he's stressed
he's stressed then it's more of a mental
thing it's more of a mental issue that
he's going through
hey man i don't know ask your dad there
might be i think that there's a problem
yeah there should there's a reason
probably that he's stressed he might be
dealing with something that you don't
know about yeah you're right i'm telling
you about and your badge troubles
tell your grandfather trying to tell me
like kind of ease up on
them your dad's actually a really sweet
guy yeah
super strong um very sweet guy and um
your grandfather's saying give him a
break like your grandfather's like chill
out
yeah that makes sense
yeah yeah we go at it i'm very hard on
them your grandfather's saying to just
chill out on him because when the day
does come that he does pass away you're
going to feel really bad about it
so he's saying to start to soothe the
[ __ ] over now
that makes sense okay not that there's
anything wrong with your dad
besides the whatever stress or mental
illness well he's
but he sensed it he's very very simple
super sensitive is he really
super sensitive super opinionated wow
yeah but you just have to he's basically
been a bit older
yeah huh okay hold on wait smaller
but he also can't he's smaller bill yeah
i was literally just going to say he's a
little bit oh no i was saying
uh smarter no he's he my dad's he's
smaller than me but he's
he's probably six three two fifteen but
in like crazy shape
wow he comes off to be honest with you
though in all reality he comes off
smaller in my vid like in how i see each
other the way i see him his energy i see
him a little bit like
his energy is a little bit and it could
just be what he's going through it's
like a friend
it's not it's a little frailty there's
something happening
he's feeling a little frail interesting
he's not feeling as strong as he used to
feel
because he's coming off like um like i'm
seeing him almost like this isn't what
he is but he's almost like the way i'm
seeing him
no who's the jewish um director
neurotic um his daughter
uh woody allen yes i'm that that's the
energy he's giving me he's giving me
woody allen energy so that's how i was
seeing him okay
well so he's going through the library
he's going through something oh wow he's
handsome brendan yeah
is it you right there on the right or
which one that's me and both of them
that's tiger
and that's my dad and that that because
we always go to the car show so that's
us at porsche and that's me and tiger at
porsche
car show the car is he skinnier than you
your dad
yeah he's skinnier he's in better shape
but i'm seeing him skinny he's
definitely skinnier he's definitely
definitely i'm going to move on but
definitely call him and reach out and
see what he's going through there's
something going on i think physically i
think he's like dealing with some kind
of physical thing and that's also why
he's scared of caroma okay or maybe yeah
no
no no no no no yeah nothing maybe a cold
yeah
no just something yeah maybe he's
terrified of crime he has diabetes
yeah maybe you can't find it well there
you go diabetes yeah he's diabetes
and that's what he's scared of with
corona because you know if you have an
underlying health condition
it really helps diet if it gets thrown
away
nothing can't find the remote or can't
yeah just something small
thomas if so if people want to get
readings where can they get them at
where can they get this
connection like um just go to my
instagram it's thomasdale5
and they can see all of the reviews i
have videos on there where people
there's over 100 reviews from all people
who've done the readings
and they could just go on thomasdale5 on
instagram
you could put your profile blocked if
you feel like you need to
not you know if you don't trust because
i have no desire i do six of these a day
five days a week
i haven't i have no time to be searching
through people's [ __ ] instagram
right so put your [ __ ] on block and come
and see me come out check out the
reviews
and you can experience it for yourself
it's like like i said like this is loose
right now where there's a lot going on
we're always kind of laughing connecting
but when it's one-on-one it really is an
experience and i'm gonna i can get in
there and i do work with people
i have ongoing people that come back
because it's energy
i mean if you believe in energy you
believe that this ex it's just energy
i'm not saying
there's like you know like it's not like
that it's like
this is just your energy it's part of
your well-being it's part of your body
right good for you man yeah good for you
yeah i gotta i think i got to get in for
a one-on-one session man and uh
seriously dude i definitely would love
to do it sounds like
you know like just private me and you
know and i can get you know dig in there
and like help you get i can give you
insight and i can give you clarity on
things
as well as connect you with others if
that's what you want but i could as the
heyoka empath
i can unveil your truth and and i can
help you see the things that your
your human mind won't allow you to see
all right thomasdale5 people can check
it out man thanks for jumping on with us
for a little bit today
yeah absolutely yeah we love you man i
love you yeah i miss you man
thomas would you do a one-on-one with me
i want to show them how positive my
energy is
i i listen i'm all i'm all about working
through
difficult people
i don't have a desire to prove anything
to anybody and because i've never been
that way even as a comedy i never had a
desire to prove things to people
so if you want to get help and you want
to reach out
yeah he needs help yeah you need
something yeah he does actually
pay for a session we're gonna right now
we're gonna buy a session from you
thomas
so we're gonna book uh the real nick
davis at your instagram no no the ebook
oh real nick davis uh who's a gambler
don't tell me too much no no i don't
want to know anything sorry
a man of risk we'll call him
um but we're gonna buy we're gonna get
them a session and uh
so that you guys can do that together
and uh 100 i'll take care of that
and uh and then i yeah i should probably
hitch up for one too man especially
since we know each other it might be
helpful to have somebody with some
insight
one thousand percent man i honestly
can't yeah i'm gonna call my dad
i'm gonna call my dad yeah yeah call me
that find out about that um you know
definitely find out about that and see
theo find out about your sister what's
going on with that
ooh reconnect with the sis yeah you're
right i should i do need to reconnect
with her and your mom yeah she's
struggling i think she's stressed out
about something which i think is your
sister and having to do with that
yeah okay i appreciate anyone else yeah
just check me out thomas
you're the best man yeah
you guys see you man wow that's wild man
how do you guys feel huh
you know
can he hear a snake what do you think
i mean i don't know what to think i
think he was right about it i don't know
what this
yeah you feel like he was right about
nick chappelle you don't
you're not into it [ __ ] no yeah but
meaning
it's not that you don't believe thomas i
don't want to do that
okay i i mean i freak out in general
and you know and to know some futuristic
[ __ ] or whatever
i'm in future or just like i don't know
i've
it happens it happens that's the kind of
person i roll like like
how i roll what about you cat do you
think do
did that compare to like what that guy
mun did or was that
it's it seems pretty close with the
exception that thomas was wearing a
shirt
yeah if you had a shirt off i've been a
little like
yeah can you put a shirt on i think the
big things you fear whenever
it's almost interesting because if you
go to talk to a medium a science man or
you know a moon man or whatever they
call it um
because that's the original astronaut as
people like that when we couldn't get
into space you talk to somebody that
could get out there and tell you what
it's like yeah yeah and people like damn
you know you say yup that's it yeah uh
but i think there's fear of what they're
gonna tell you
i was i was nervous weren't you i'm a
little bit nervous
uh yeah i guess i get a little bit
nervous i don't want anybody really to
die
you know i don't want to be gay yeah
not that i don't want to be gay i think
it's great but i just i'm already
dealing with women i've already put in
all of this time
yeah i'm not trying to be also gay yeah
yeah you know
you're gonna restart at the starting
yeah
it's been a [ __ ] journey man not them
in a different race
you know what i'm saying yeah it's hard
enough with these you know some of these
legit [ __ ] out there
you know no
i thought it was interesting you got
that thick [ __ ] trying to get through
though man
oh dude you're there in your pants yeah
what happened
oh look they got some thick girls in my
past bro
trying to sneak through the portal
trying to get to you any way they can
you ain't answering the dms daddy what's
her name what's her name i gotta hide
the snacks
man i don't know her first name but the
last name is fogle yeah
i see
i love how typical southern my sister
gets knocked up in everything no matter
what it is i'm doing it yeah yeah i
think one of your younger siblings is
knocked up yeah i'm like well she's nine
she didn't go to liz she did use the
frequent knicks
so maybe she has had some issues yes
some trauma
ah what's this nick
uh oh this is uh king or stingit i
thought it was anna hernandez for
i'm sorry aaron rodgers that's why i
thought you had something for us
aaron rodgers hernandez is who this guy
looks like huh he is from
wisconsin maybe brendan theo i have the
king understand it for you
in my wood shop i like to make cutting
boards
and sell them online a couple years ago
i got a
message from a customer that said do you
make charcuterie boards
and i thought to myself listen i'm not
french i have no idea what that word
uh over the last couple years
charcuterie has become popular
and uh i have to say i've been to a
couple weddings
it's got dried meats cheeses nuts
berries
yeah i know i think i'm becoming a
charcuterie fan
wow anyway king intersting at shark
cuttery boards
gang gang buzz buzz that one's sick yeah
that one kind of hurts my eyes because
like a prism but
yeah that's that honeycomb i bought a
cutting board from him and is this one
of his neck
uh that is not this is actually a
complete coincidence my girlfriend made
charcuterie for ufc 252 we had some
friends over here
new place and she's making that this
morning and i'm in the kitchen going
through submissions and this guy popped
up oh wow it was
pretty it was pretty wild thomas didn't
say that what's his company do you know
i'm looking him up yeah i need a new
cutting board
you do yeah let's get one let's get a
couple nicks
his name is david schammer
he didn't leave any other information um
maybe uh by thursday we'll see if he's
got a contact and we'll put it up on the
screen
that's a beautiful little cutting board
uh-huh yeah now a lot of in
in a lot of asian culture you guys cut
something right in the air right you
guys don't use it
yeah you're not going to waste yeah
absolutely it's a waste of a dish
yep so you got to train real hard when
you're a kid we're the original fruit
ninja
damn because now it's a nap this is such
a typical white thing we need like a
safe board to cut on you know um
salt bae does in the air too though
doesn't he salt bae doesn't like that in
here
yeah he does you know there's a rumor
that he stole that whole thing off of
somebody
what cutting meat huh cutting meat and
salting it
yeah you think i didn't think he was the
original did you
no but doing that a little uh you know
feed the baby deal or whatever oh no
that's that's
and one dog he got that from basketball
did he yep
can you google that uh salt based steals
um something i think you stole that from
the gay community
oh i could see that dropping that song
[Music]
yeah
actually tip skimming bay
oh chef engaging some shitty wage
practice that is oh you just wasn't
tipping people out
i could see that yeah
tourists are set on fire did that say
that chaos at salt bays
now sobe has restaurants in miami and
new york yeah
oh hell yeah
four tourists are set on fire at
instagram star salt basis
istanbul restaurant probably for
what sex before marriage what do they do
over there i don't know what the rules
are
istanbul anyone know about it no
no i think yeah if you're a woman or you
can't drive i get i don't know what they
did to them
they're trying to get lit on some drinks
and just got out of hand
what do they do is that one they put the
with the flaming uh
huh what is wrong with people man people
can't just [ __ ] eat anymore
are you what is wrong with you guys you
gotta have this guy come with a table
and do this
you gotta have somebody with a [ __ ]
flamethrower
you gotta have somebody [ __ ] get out
there and beat the [ __ ] out of a sirloin
in front of you
you gotta have somebody drop kick a damn
uh dessert in your mouth
like you just it never ends man people
he's trying to take to the next level
yeah there's always somebody all gotta
like this let's get right
in taco like that where are you going
what are you doing cat liked it though
it looks fun okay
uh i'd rather not say okay
okay mind-boggling not mind-blowing
it does look like a very sexual
experience for food
but yeah he did stick that finger in a
little dude is it
now tell me this is it an asian culture
thing that you guys like more excitement
with the food you guys have the okay
let's eat sushi
denise is back you guys have the let's
do the you know the the skillet in the
air you guys have the
the the experience at the mandarin
kitchen where you guys are cooking the
meat on the grill
benihana is flipping [ __ ] yeah shrimp
and
you hide a [ __ ] shrimp in your
mother's breast you know
uh fortune cookie yeah why you can't
just have a regular
korean bbq it's the freshest you can
possibly eat it at that time
they cook it and then boom so that's why
i think korean bbq but i don't know
about vietnamese culture and
flashy stuff there i think it's
something that asians do to try to sell
food to white people
that's true that's another thing okay i
think that's a secret and you know what
it worked
it worked really good because i feel
like a lot of non-asians think we're
like mythological creatures as it is so
we just kind of play into it
it's all really a money scheme yep i
don't
like that now that makes sense i really
wish thomas would have read chin or cat
i feel like we should pay to get them
readings as well
yeah yeah maybe we'll do a group some
group readings
with them one-on-one things could be
extra patreon content ooh we can put
some on patreon and maybe we'll do a
highlight reel that we put on to the
clips channel
that's a good idea would you guys agree
to do a reading on a chappelle looks
very nervous very nervous
what are you worried about what happened
to you bro whatever a lot of things
happen to me
we'd like to hear about it oh yeah what
do you guys want to do you didn't kill
nobody didn't you
did i yeah no you hang on any libraries
did you
no how much did you guys all believe in
what he was doing like you guys
especially because you didn't say
anything really
i believed it i believe that stuff
that's why i don't [ __ ] with it
yeah i believe it specifically him
though when you saw it when he heard his
readings
what did you guys think i think i could
do it theo
see nick's the guy in the crowd not
laughing going i'm funnier than that
i know yeah yeah nixon thank god i could
do that
then get up here then get up here let me
know how it goes for you
yeah then get a barrette and [ __ ] yeah
put it
put your hair in them your hair is long
enough for that ponytail
it might be this is the longest get up
get out there nick start doing it
that's what i'll say did i do i i mean i
think first of all
we put him in a very tough environment
ah the toughest i don't know i mean i'm
i'm skeptical but i'm not like
i'm not anti thomas being a mind reader
what the [ __ ] you call it right
claire you're on vaughn i just don't i
clairvoyant clearly
i just i don't know i don't i don't know
enough about it
empath i don't know i'm not hating on
them
no no but i don't know skepticism is
what makes it work and what makes it
interesting too is the fact that people
are
like the fact you can be like
convinced or the fact that you can be
enlightened like so skepticism he said
get a dog
my girl [ __ ] hates dogs yeah dude if
somebody knocked my door in the middle
of the night was like hey come outside
see this
magic trick i'm gonna be skeptical as
[ __ ] but then if it's good magic
yeah i hope he comes back i'll sit by
the window and look but i'm not gonna go
out there
is that a magician that's john edwards
maybe one of the originals
i don't trust him i dm'd him today did
you yeah did he not want to come in
i didn't oh he didn't see it yet let's
get chris angel on this [ __ ]
he's not a he's not a mind reader but
they have those skills though
his show is called chris mind reader
mind freak my fault i thought he was
just a magician calm down no
no let's get that [ __ ] uh jersey
short uh
long island medium let's get her
long-fingered [ __ ] in here
whoa okay all right so where's that now
yeah
i'm not gonna come now she already knew
he was going to say it
yeah she's like brendan's talking [ __ ]
oh yeah did you guys pick up on stuff
that he got wrong look at those freaking
cannolis
right off of her shoulders man i like
that and look at them front tips
two meatballs hanging out the front
there yeah is that what is that
okay i'm talking about that regatta new
jersey hush puppies
look at that regatta hanging off the
front huh yeah that rigatoni
here's somebody right here here's
somebody i thought from nick's library
i'm just joking here's a here's a
beautiful young fellow with his child
right here
what up king of this thing this is a mod
coming at you from erie pennsylvania
i got a king in her stinger for you
breast milk
mmm i know a lot of bodybuilders drink
that [ __ ] no they do
and i'm honestly starting to believe it
i mean look at this dude
he's ripped jacked yeah oh
yep better call baby you saw it on his
little
you know yeah get golden snitch sniffing
around that baby right now
i want him tested twice a week that's
what i'm saying man
i tell jeff novitskiy come to the crib
dude bossing in too big man i don't
trust his mom's putting something in his
juice box can you feel me
uh breast milk i'd have a little man i'm
not having a lot i'll probably pass on i
don't like
any uh male i don't like dairy i don't
like milk
yeah i don't like milk you got to but
he's talking about breast milk man he's
talking about
you know what i'm saying that now some
of them freaks out there will suck on a
girl's breast
you're i'll probably sing it too but
dude if you're trying to get them gained
summer's coming up try and get them
gains and so
because i guess there's a lot of igf-1
in breast milk and like growth hormone
for the baby
so if you're trying to you know be mr
olympia yeah shake your tip there you go
there you go now i feel like back in the
day maybe sipped a little breast milk
dude i'm not gonna lie i paid a premium
for it as well
dude if i drank it i'd drink it right at
the end of a damn needle bruh
okay i was doing it
do you know what's easier to see a
steroids then it is easier to sneak into
a pregnant woman's house
it's a lot suck it's a lot it's a lot
it's a lot how bad you want it man you
want to be slow how bad you want it bro
dude this ain't nick's library where you
should just
get whatever you want okay nate tells on
you
nick is so pissed you keep bringing up
his library for some reason the la
crosse public library run won awards in
wisconsin
every year what awards yeah whatever
[Laughter]
he's so proud of that dude every library
won awards bro
it's a freaking library
dude the library is already insane man
the libraries are insane all right
i can't hear the teacher i come around
and go yeah god dang
damn conversation we would have
a full launch spread in the [ __ ] sit
on the carpet of the library
it's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
see the [ __ ] camping trip she we
would be there when she
opened the library doors and the lady
let herself in we would
walk in with
and we would straight up be there man
and every now and then a hot chick would
come into the library yeah that's all
you could focus so rare
yeah this is the last king of their
sting it we got for today christina
position
huh about terminator 5 mariah from new
jersey
oh what's up mariah got a quick king at
her sing it for you guys what do you
think about
girls with gaps in their teeth oh damn
michael's straight what do you think
because you girls got one
love you guys gang gang buzz buzz gang
gang
i think that's it's dope god made you
like that for a reason man the worst one
people cover them up
they get veneers or something rock the
gap i used to have gap man
i knew it mine's gone i saw three gaps
though
that's just bad teeth she just has that
oh you just had bad teeth
i couldn't eat man i couldn't keep food
in my mouth i put supermouth coming
right back you got a purty mouth
whoa oh [ __ ] what am i talking you gotta
gab dog yeah
well let's bring up they have a
beautiful model that has a gap too her
name is lauren will you look her up
beautiful model madonna has a gap
does she yeah uh michael strahan who
else
we're talking about women becky g used
to have a gap and then she got that
fixed hey why don't people get it that's
7 10 split baby that's what i'm saying
straight hand got that 7 10 split man
that's a big gap
yeah here's the yeah but also if you
think about how wide maybe his
his whole bone structure is it just
didn't make sense
that many teeth aren't going to be able
to get the job he got tired
his teeth are all holding each other's
hands like this yeah they got tired man
yeah man because he got can we look up
beautiful
model teeth gap older older
older yeah this lady's a senior i think
her yeah on the right yeah right there
what's her name
who's that lauren
aykroyd or something yeah you got him
for a reason man i think you rocked that
[ __ ]
yeah there was a ring girl for bellator
that's how jay bryant
she's so hot she's super smoking
that's her laura hutton laura hutt and
lauren hutton
uh yeah hey bring up jade bryce
uh yeah this is something theo can slam
his dick to a book later
bring this up if you have a painting of
her i might be interested
yeah it's got to be a painting jade
bryce
yeah she is so freaking hot yep she got
a gap
yes yes sir
yep just click on her teeth i think
cat's better looking
cat doesn't have a gap oh thanks there
cat doesn't have any i still think
that's prettier though
there you go and also that woman just
got out of the shower where is she
she's working out oh my bad debate club
jade bryce
or lauren hutton what do you say
debate club uh jade or lauren no they're
both beautiful ladies that they almost
these ladies almost look similar a
little bit if you look
like a mother-daughter type of situation
yeah now
is there um i think freckles are cool
too
anyway that's freckles you don't have
any freckles well you're getting crazy
man you don't like freckles
what are you just in a giving mood today
yeah no one has freckles you already
said he looked real tan yeah would you
watch a miracle on 34th street yesterday
or something did come in tan
and we'll close it out with this uh king
interesting
what's up brandon uh this is chris here
from des moines i got a king understand
it for you
i breathalyzers drink anymore i've been
silver for quite a while now but that
wasn't always the case so
long story short they gave your boy one
of these because they got one too many
dui's
yup by that i mean four
hit this button when you want to go the
supermarket it takes five minutes to
get ice cream maybe offered to drive on
a first date
those things still don't stop you though
because you have your buddy blowing to
it
or your child wow really
damn need a little heavy too yeah
sometimes i'll get lucky
and it'll go off on sitting at a
drive-through window or
maybe i'm sitting in traffic i'll be
blown into it oh yeah they randomly
over make eye contact and they're not
cheap either um but anyways kanger sting
breathalyzers gang gang buzz buzz listen
man
what do you say b they're they're safe
you know you've got a drinking problem
listen you get one of those after
usually your second or third time
i know from experience i've never had it
myself but i had a
a close friend that had to do it i had
to blow into it okay did you yeah i did
do we know him or not
nope you don't know her but uh
[Laughter]
it was a problem man really and they're
expensive too
they're expensive now but they but they
passed a rule
because three strikes and you're out in
denver three strikes if you get three
duis you go
you go to prison three strikes you're
out oh wow
damn nick what's up nick did you my uh
sister because drinking's huge in
wisconsin her and her husband got one
for parties
it's a little party favor and everybody
passes around and see who can get the
high score
also a good way to get corona it comes
with uh
separate uh sticks for everybody oh
that's to test your alcohol
level oh yeah you know what you know
what you can't play anymore i was
thinking about this last night for
whatever reason like midnight you know
you can't play anymore because the
corona no more beer pong oh yeah no more
beer pong
talk about a corona spreader but no one
throw the ball and then your hands drink
it and they throw it back
everybody's around i think they've been
playing it differently because now they
just put water in it yeah and they just
hold their
their beers and they take us they'll
take a drink yeah y'all gay
people they were a little ahead of the
corona curve like yeah
we could still play yeah we had the
grassroots version where yeah you played
like and it was just nasty in a barn we
did yeah that's gross
y'all ever done uh edward 40 hands that
was my game oh i love that game
my hands go numb would be yeah but then
it was dangerous because you had you had
glass bottles
tied to your hands your hands no it was
great it was one of my favorite games
i did with mickey's oh yeah those are
good man gangster doug
well this fella i'm saying look if you i
think it's just crazy how
how like you know there's
everything you do it's like we just the
rules keep
it getting bent out so that we could
just keep doing it more you can get
three dui's you know
it's a lot man it's a lot i mean after
two you're [ __ ] you got one of those
yeah i think they should have something
almost a little bit more
where if you want to get your car to
start you need to stand on top of your
car and do like two games of ddr
you know that's fair like to just
something that shows a little bit more
that has a little bit more of a social
ramification you know what i'm saying
you run a mile outdoor under 10 minutes
yeah
you got to go run them out do something
good for yourself so then it'll leave
you to uh
oh yeah there i am right there here's
somebody right here who's obviously has
a drug alcohol problem that was me in uh
college oh there you go yeah edward 40
here too much table i know what is that
that's too much
uh 40s or 10. what's what's around
that's athletics
looks like you're carrying two beehives
yeah bro it looks like you're making
molotov cocktails bro like you're the
[ __ ] kimbo slice of [ __ ] ice cream
that's how you do this you look like
wesley snipes and white men can't jump
i do you look like wesley wipes dude
[ __ ] toilet paper in your hands no
that's how you do it get that bud ice
you you you had a real problem huh yeah
yeah yeah would you get all hammered you
like back flips and [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah you're that guy yeah
doing cartwheels naked am i right
cartwheel's naked yeah yeah bro you
should have to blow into a breathalyzer
before you're allowed to do cartwheels
after you've been
drinking i think no i could yeah i had
it like like it's one of those things
it's like
i don't know it's like riding a bike you
just when when did you know you hit rock
bottom
oh nick sneaking another picture of him
in here
there's nick at the library
and that's the nine-year-old girl yeah
[Laughter]
thanks nick but when did you know you
hit rock bottom chappelle
uh i mean not to get all emotional after
my brother died oh wow
you know you got a drinking problem oh
man yeah were you drinking or where were
you drinking mostly
i loved wild turkey oh wow yeah that was
my choice that's that gasolina
i know that's what everyone says every
time i drink that gasoline like
uh you know i you know i actually i
would just go get it at the bars i would
go sit at a like like i would go to a
bar
and i would sit at i was the guy that
was sitting in the stool and just
[ __ ] drinking are you rich rich
yeah you rich rich doing on the bar i
know i spent a lot of my money at a bar
a lot well here's my uh
were you shooting the [ __ ] there yeah
what are you doing there uh
i used to go to this bar back home
called there's a couple of ones bikini
lounge and the other one is called
crescent crescent ballroom and the
crescent ballroom
they used to play that what's that lady
that uh older ladies about that kid rock
song it's kind of slow
no the lady they said some damn no
they have it on their on the tv it's a
lady that talks about sex she's old
sue joe hansen oh yeah yeah uh dr ruth
dr ruth dr that lady they would they
would play that and i'd just sit there
and
and just drink by themselves by myself
no company huh no i didn't need nobody
what do i need yeah who do you need man
buddy
got dr ruth yeah i love dwight now would
you mix the
liquor with some pills or your drink it
but you don't need no friends
i would strictly everything everything
scares me would scare me but alcohol
yeah dr ruth's still alive or she's
still dtf
dude she's dying she no she didn't she
did yeah i'm pretty sure she's really
old back there
did not die yeah 100 she's 4-7 go look
born only is she yeah she's 92. oh 92
told you she's not dead wow she got so
much
information on sex that's probably why
she's still alive
exactly but has she been doing sex you
think
remember her who dr sujo hansen she was
on tv late night too i i i learned more
from her than dr ruby
i remember sue i remember that doctor
first of all
i learned more what kind of guy works at
a library and goes to learn from like a
seven-year-old woman on television at
night she taught me the come hither
motion
gosh you know what i'm mad is that too
much
brendan and theo fighter and weight i
got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude got a
pack of matches in his pockets at all
times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
king
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you